the war in afghanistan is now over joe
biden has decided to pull out all troops
afghanistan has fallen to the taliban
and so now we have to ask ourselves what
was the war for in order to understand
what actually happened in afghanistan
and whether defeat was inevitable we
have to look at the history of
afghanistan so today we're going to go
through the entire history of u.s
afghanistan relations and we're going to
trace exactly where this war went right
and where it went wrong
let's begin in the 1950s relations
between the u.s and afghanistan actually
date back to then that's when the
eisenhower administration was seeking to
bolster ties with the newly formed
afghan government in order to prevent
them from becoming a soviet satellite
state this was the middle of the cold
war so in 1959 for example president
eisenhower actually flew to afghanistan
he led a motorcade to kabul meeting with
the king and the prime minister between
the 50s and 1979 the united states
granted about 500 million dollars in
loans grants and commodities a bunch of
ngos non-governmental organizations were
working in afghanistan to try to help
the economy over there afghanistan's
government remained officially neutral
during the cold war accepting aid from
both sides in 1973 general mohammed
daoud khan formerly the prime minister
of afghanistan overthrew the king whose
name was muhammad zahir shah he replaced
the regime with the people's democratic
party of afghanistan again this
government remained somewhere in between
with regard to the communist ussr and
the united states then in 1978 khan was
killed in a communist coup and was
replaced by members of the communist
party the new regime said it wasn't
officially in league with the soviet
union but it pretty much was they
started cementing ties with the ussr
they infamously replaced the country's
black red and green islamic flag with a
knock off of the soviet union's flag
that coup resulted in a move toward more
political repression combined with a
communistic land reform program and then
in february 1979 the american ambassador
to afghanistan a man named adolf dubs
was kidnapped under mysterious
circumstances murdered by his kidnappers
the united states responded by
withdrawing all support from the afghan
government so now the afghan government
is basically a proxy for the ussr
meanwhile chaos is breaking out in the
new afghan government as nur muhammad
taraki one of the founding members of
the afghan communist party and the new
prime minister is murdered by supporters
of another communist leader named
hafizullah amin the soviet union invaded
in order to bolster the deputy prime
minister a guy named babraka carmel the
new regime resulted in the rise of the
famous mujahideen this is 1980 by 1982
thanks to the war some 2.8 million
afghans had fled to pakistan another 1.5
million to iran the western powers began
funding the afghan mujahideen in order
to stymie the soviets the mujahideen at
this time it's a blanket name for a wide
variety of disorganized groups it wasn't
like a giant coordinated fighting force
it ranged from rural fighters
domestically driven who wanted the
overthrow of the communist regime to
people who wanted the imposition of a
total islamic state the sort of
predecessors to the taliban in 1989 the
u.s pakistan afghanistan and the soviet
union signed a peace agreement
guaranteeing afghan independence and the
removal of all soviet troops in 1992 the
mujahideen overthrew the soviet puppet
government that had been left in place
and formed an islamic state with a guy
named borhanudin rabbani as president
now by this point afghanistan had been
in a state of war for at least a decade
and a half kabul was awash in bloodshed
tribal warfare and this leads to the
rise of the taliban so in 1994 mullah
omar who is a religious leader and now
military leader creates the taliban it's
an islamic radical group consolidating
under the banner of sharia law their big
promise is that they were going to end
the conflict they would end the civil
war the taliban quickly gained power
they won kandahar and in 1996 they
seized kabul and with it control of the
country the new taliban government is
only recognized by three countries on
planet earth saudi arabia the united
arab emirates and pakistan they all were
allies of the new taliban regime
meanwhile the taliban offered
peripatetic terrorist osama bin laden a
place to stay bin laden had originally
fought with the mujahideen in the 1980s
under the banner of a group he called
al-qaeda bin laden had returned to saudi
arabia after the soviet withdrawal from
afghanistan he'd been welcomed as sort
of a hero in 1994 he was expelled
because he kept backing terror attacks
on american targets he had then taken
refuge in sudan he was expelled from
sudan in 1996. in 1996 the taliban take
him back into afghanistan and upon his
return to afghanistan bin laden releases
a fatwa declaring jihad against the
united states and then of course
launches a series of increasingly
spectacular terrorist attacks on
american targets in 1998 bin laden
orders the bombing of the u.s embassies
in kenya and tanzania killing 224 people
in 2000 bin laden orders the bombing of
the uss cole killing 17 americans and
then of course september 11th
in the aftermath of september 11th the
united states called on the taliban to
turn bin laden over the taliban refused
saying that only allah could provide for
the overthrow of their regime instead
the united states did on october 7 2001
the united states and uk began operation
enduring freedom a bombing campaign
against the taliban within two months by
december 17th 2001 the taliban had been
driven from power completely osama bin
laden for his part had escaped across
the border to pakistan in december the
united nations set up a conference to
decide on the future government of
afghanistan that agreement led to the
installation of a man named hamid karzai
as the interim administration head he
would later be confirmed to head the
transitional government in june of 2002.
just a couple months before that in
april president george w bush announced
a new marshall plan for afghanistan
congress appropriated 38 billion dollars
in humanitarian aid and reconstruction
assistance to afghanistan from not only
intelligence but from the history of
military conflict in afghanistan
it's been one of initial success
followed by long years of floundering
and ultimate failure
we're not going to repeat that mistake
in november 2002 in a concession to the
international nature of the effort in
afghanistan the u.s created a civil
affairs framework to work with the
united nations and non-governmental
organizations the reconstruction effort
would chiefly be led by quote unquote
provincial reconstruction teams the
disorganized and discombobulated series
of groups seeking security and
development across the country in may
2003 defense secretary donald rumsfeld
declared an end to major combat in
afghanistan that announcement came at
the same time as george w bush's
declaration that the fighting in iraq
had been ended and the infamous mission
accomplished banner flew aboard an
aircraft carrier at this point there
were only eight thousand american troops
in afghanistan the mission was said to
have shifted to quote-unquote stability
stabilization reconstruction and
activities in august 2003 nato took
control of the international security
forces in afghanistan the so-called isaf
forces would eventually number 65 000
troops from 42 countries in january 2004
a group of afghan delegates announced
the formation of an afghan constitution
in october of 2004 karzai was elected
president in the first democratic
election in afghanistan's history in may
2005 karzai and bush announced an
agreement as strategic partners in which
the u.s would be given access to afghan
military facilities to fight terrorism
which of course was the entire goal of
the war and the united states would
continue to provide aid and assistance
to afghan security forces in september
there was another election held for the
council of the people council of elders
and local councils and more than 6
million afghans turned out to vote by
july 2006 however the successes in
afghanistan were starting to fade
suicide attacks rocketed from 27 in 2005
to 139 in 2006 the central government
appeared unable in many cases to provide
basic services in the countryside the
small footprint of the international
forces allowed the resurgence of the
insurgency by november the west was
beginning to lose its will for war as
well at a nato summit secretary general
jacques hoop sheffer announced that nato
would seek to turn over security to the
afghan national army by 2008 in 2007
defense secretary robert gates ripped
our nato allies saying quote at this
time many allies are unwilling to share
the risks commit the resources and
follow through on collective commitments
to this mission into each other as a
result we risk allowing what has been
achieved in afghanistan to slip away
upon taking office in february 2009
barack obama announced that afghanistan
was the good war and he also announced a
semi-surge 17 000 more troops to
afghanistan to join the 37 000 troops
already in afghanistan as of january
defense secretary robert gates said the
american mission in afghanistan had been
too broad and said the goal instead
should merely have been to prevent
terrorism rather than nation build in
march obama announced the united states
would increase aids in pakistan and send
4 000 troops to afghanistan to train the
afghan army and police force
nato signed onto that limited mission in
may in july 2009 the united states
launched a major offensive in helmand
province always the most troublesome
province in afghanistan to bolster
support for the local police and restore
government services by august u.s forces
in the country numbered between 60 000
and 68 000. in november 2009 the afghan
election came under serious criticism
for corruption karzai won another term
but barely in fact he tried to stop a
runoff election he was forced to conduct
one by international pressure but his
opponent had pulled out of the runoff
leading to serious allegations of
corruption and election fixing in
december 2009 obama announced another
surge committing another 30 000 troops
to the fight at the same time he
announced for the first time the united
states would start withdrawing troops
july 2011 would mark the beginning of
the us pull out of course simultaneously
putting in troops and announcing that
you're going to start withdrawing troops
in a final pullout is likely to lead to
an increase in violence that's precisely
what happened in november 2010 nato
countries signed an agreement to hand
over full responsibility for afghan
security to afghan forces by the end of
2014. on may 1st 2011 osama bin laden
was killed this allowed the west to
declare some semblance of victory in
afghanistan obama began talking
simultaneously about withdrawing nearly
the entire surge force similarly obama
announced the u.s was holding
preliminary peace talks with the taliban
itself during the same period obama
announced his plan to withdraw all
combat troops by 2014 in line with nato
not surprisingly the taliban responded
with aggression in march 2012 the
taliban pulled out of the talks
completely at about the same time u.s
defense secretary leon panetta announced
the u.s would seek to conclude combat
missions by as early as mid-2013 and
shift instead to security assistance in
june 2013 afghan forces were granted
control over national security that same
day resumption of talks between the us
and taliban were announced undercutting
the afghan government in may 2014 obama
announced most u.s forces would be
withdrawn from afghanistan by the end of
2016. by the end of 2014 less than 10
000 american troops would be in
afghanistan the map shows the story as
the united states began to withdraw the
taliban began to strengthen by 2017
afghanistan had become a relatively
stable stalemate u.s troop levels had
stabilized at or around 10 000 in
afghanistan since the mission shift in
2014. the government was controlling
approximately 60 of districts in the
country from time to time troop numbers
would fluctuate in response to
emergencies in 2017 for example the u.s
delegated marines to hellman province in
a support role to prevent its complete
collapse that same year president trump
announced that while he would love to
pull out of afghanistan the situation on
the ground would have to dictate whether
that would be an available option in
january 2018 the taliban launched a
series of terrorist attacks in kabul
itself killing 115 people and by 2019
the trump administration opened
negotiations with the taliban the deal
would presumably have the united states
withdrawing troops in exchange for the
taliban pledging to prevent terrorist
groups from using the country as a base
in september however trump broke off the
peace talks the following february the
us and taliban signed a deal along the
lines proposed by the trump
administration but the taliban continued
to pursue terror attacks on afghan
forces sensing a breach between the us
government and the afghan government the
u.s continued to pull out troops in
november 2020 after the election u.s
defense secretary christopher miller
announced plans to bring american troop
numbers down to just 2 500. then on
april 14th president biden announced the
us would withdraw all forces by
september 11 2021. the speed with which
the afghan forces collapsed was
frightening but it was a direct response
to the withdrawal of all close air
support and civilian contractor support
by the biden administration the afghan
military had been built to work with us
military they required the support of
close air support from the us military
and the required american civilian
contractors to service the afghan air
force all of that was withdrawn by biden
in july biden infamously said
afghanistan would not look like saigon
and that the taliban had no capabilities
akin to the viet cong it is not at all
comfortable by august 15th the taliban
had taken over kabul alrighty we'll get
to more on this in just one second first
i've been traveling a lot and i've slept
in a bunch of different places recently
and i really had a tough time sleeping
because i did not have my helix sleep
mattress the mattress made just for me
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made for somebody else
with helix you're getting a mattress you
know will be perfect for the way you
sleep everybody's unique helix knows
that so they have several different
mattress models to choose from if soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot even a helix plus mattress for plus
size folks i took the helix quiz i
wanted a firm mattress and i happened to
sleep on my stomach and they actually
just made the mattress for me not only
is the helix sleep mattress good for me
it's good for my wife i actually got one
for my sister for her wedding it's been
awesome getting unboxing videos from so
many of you who also found the helix
sleep mattress of your dreams so if you
are looking for a mattress you take the
quiz you order the mattress you match to
the mattress comes directly to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to a mattress store again helix is
awesome you don't need to take my word
for it helix was awarded the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
and wired magazine just head on over to
helixsleep.com
take their two minute sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that'll give you the best sleep of your
life they have a 10-year warranty you
get to try it out for a hundred nights
risk free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
right now helix is offering up to 200
off all of your mattress orders and two
free pillows for our listeners at helix
sleep.com ben it's the best deal of the
year
helixsleep.com for the special deal
let's talk for a second about where
things were before biden decided to do
what biden eventually did namely hand
over the entire country to the taliban
here is a chart of american troop levels
in afghanistan as you can see the chart
shows that at the 2014 mark the troop
levels in afghanistan dropped
dramatically all the way down to 10 000
troops 12 000 troops and then finally
2500 troops bottom line is this there
was a stalemate in afghanistan that
stalemate had been held by a minimum
number of american troops with a very
minimum number of american deaths by the
end of the war there had been not one
american combat casualty since february
of 2020. the notion that this was either
an endless war or that the taliban were
about to overrun the country unless the
united states pulled out is
unsupportable by the fact the entire
intelligence community was warning biden
that the likely outcome of this
withdrawal was the taliban taking back
the country the only question was how
fast that would happen biden decided we
had to withdraw forthwith for no
apparent reason he was simply committed
to the path of withdrawal it didn't
matter that 10 to 15 000 americans might
get stuck in afghanistan and that we
would have to bribe the taliban to get
them out it didn't matter that maybe a
hundred thousand afghan allies and their
families would get stuck in afghanistan
and probably will end up stuck there
murdered by the taliban joe biden wanted
things his way he got them his way and
according to joe biden he's made zero
mistakes you don't think this could have
been handled this actually could have
been handled
better in any way no mistakes
no i i don't think it could have been
handled in a way that there
we're going to go back in hindsight and
look but the idea that somehow
there's a way to have gotten out without
chaos ensuing i don't know how that
happens the initial war in afghanistan
was not a mistake the taliban was the
group that had harbored al-qaeda refused
to turn over osama bin laden in the
aftermath of september 11th there were
many mistakes made along the progression
of the afghan wars path but the original
war itself was launched with wide
bipartisan support for a very good
reason to stop al-qaeda and destroy them
it is worthwhile to note for all of
those who believe that the united states
must remove itself from endless wars
that the history of the united states
and foreign military occupations is a
history whereby corrupt military
dictatorships often become our chief
allies in democracy south korea only
exists because the united states
remained in south korea to this day with
tens of thousands of troops south korea
held its first election in the 1980s the
korean war ended in 1953. the same thing
is true of taiwan the united states
essentially removed all support from
shanghai sheck in china as of 1947 1948
the united states continued support to
taiwan despite it being a rather corrupt
military dictatorship until the 1980s
means that today taiwan is a democracy
very often the united states has an
interest in long-term occupations but
when it comes to afghanistan we weren't
even talking about keeping tens of
thousands of troops to pacify the
countryside we were talking about
keeping a skeletal force there to simply
maintain bases against terrorism now
those bases are gone pakistan has
decided to remove all american footprint
from its country as well we have no
capacity to police the countryside of
the taliban which will now become a safe
haven for terrorism once again and our
geopolitical enemies are looking with
greedy eyes and all of our allies around
the globe china is celebrating the
united states withdrawal from
afghanistan and the subsequent collapse
of the afghan military as well as the
humanitarian crisis likely to follow
they're looking at taiwan and saying why
shouldn't we do the same thing the
taliban did except do it with regard to
taiwan russia has to be looking with
envious eyes at latvia and estonia iran
has already decided to up its terror
game terrorists all over the world are
looking at the united states and seeing
a paper tiger in the same way that osama
bin laden one saw a paper tiger in the
aftermath of the clinton
administration's decision not to do
anything about the bombings of the u.s
embassies in kenya and tanzania foreign
policy has consequences the story of
afghanistan is not the story of
inevitable defeat the story of
afghanistan is a story of cowardice by
the biden administration and it's a
story of a disaster that did not have to
happen so let's get back to the original
question was the war in afghanistan a
complete failure the answer is no the
war in afghanistan was not a complete
failure it was not an inevitable defeat
for the united states the goal of the
war was to prevent terrorism from
arising from afghan soil the united
states military did an admirable job of
that for 20 years and then the political
leadership as they so often do decided
to surrender this is not on our soldiers
our soldiers our heroes the people who
gave their lives in defense of american
freedom did so for good cause our afghan
allies did so for a good cause the
cowardice is the cowardice of our
political and military leadership alone
it is not the failure of our american
soldiers all of whom continue to perform
heroically it is just another lesson in
the long history of pusillanimous
american leadership for 20 years after 9
11 the american military prevented
afghanistan from becoming a terror
hotbed now the political leadership
class has decided to surrender
afghanistan back to the hell it was in
before we ever arrived